This is a second thought video made possible by Squarespace
make your next move with the beautiful website from Squarespace
There Are Plenty Of Theories On How Our Universe Began
But Currently The Most Prevalent Scientific Theory
Is That Everything Came Into Existence At The Single Moment Known As The Big Bang
But If Everything Was Created At This One Moment
What Came Before The Big Bang?.
As Our Understanding Has Developed We've Come To Realize
That Our Universe Is Expanding And With Our Current Technology
We Can Say With A Relative Certainty That The Big Bang
Occurred About 13.8 Billion Years Ago
Over The Years Our Space Telescopes
Have Allowed Us To Look Further And Further Back In Time
Observing The Faintest Lights Of The Universe That Formed Just
300, 000 Years After The Big Bang To Gain An
Even Better Understanding Of The Beginning Of The Universe
Scientist Use The Large Hadron Collider (CERN)
To Approximate The Conditions Of The Big Bang
On A Much Smaller Scale Of Course
But That's Is Far Back
As We Can Go And That's Just Not Good Enough Is It?.
We Humans Are Wired Within A Nit
Tendency To Assume Cause And Effect
Everything That Happens
Can Be Assume To Have A Cause Or it Wouldn't Have Happen
Right?. So If We Rewind Time
Back Through The Expansion Of The Universe Before Galaxies Formed
To The Moment Before The Explosion That Causes Everything
What Do We Find?.
Well Maybe NOTHING!.
Some Scientists Speculate That Before The Big Bang
Was A Massively Dense Infinitely Tiny Singularity
A Point Of Which Time And The Laws Of Physics Did Not Exist
If Time Didn't Exist
Then There Is No Before Others Suspect That The Big Bang
May Actually Have Been A BIG BOUNCE
Another
Universe May Have Existed Before Ours That After Many
Billions Of Years Stopped Expanding And Collapsed
In On Itself And Formed The Single Unbelievably Massive Black hole
Eventually Collapsing Into the Singularity
That exploded Into Our Current Universe
Proponents Of The Idea Suspected That The Big Bounce
Could Have Been Occurring Forever And Will Continue To Have Been Forever
Okay... But What Caused The First Universe In This Series
No One Knows For Sure Perhaps The First Universe
Was Always There And Our Human Understanding
Is Not Equipped To Accept That Fact
Albert Einstein Once
Said That Trying To Understand What Came Before The Big Bang
Is Like Trying To Figure Out Whats More North Than The North Pole
Another Hypothesis Is That
Our Universe Is Just One Of An
Infinite Number Of Universes
Each Floating Around In Some Higher Dimension
Some Scientist Suspect That
The Expansion Of Our Universe And Potentially Any Universe
Is The Effect Of A Neighboring Universe's Gravity
An When Two Or More Of This Universes Collide With Each Other
It Should Leave A Distinctive Marking In The Cosmic Microwave Background
Which We Should Be Able To Detect
The Only Problem Is We Haven't Ever Detected
Anything Of The Sort
Others Propose That A Collision Between Universes Will Spark A Cataclysmic Event
A Big Bang
And Create An Entirely New Universe
The Existence Of A Multiverse Like
This Relies Upon String Theory Being Correct
And While String Theory Does Have Traction
In The Scientific Community The Jury Is Still Out On Its Over All Acceptance
So Really The Only Honest Answer
Anyone Could Currently Give To This Question Of
What Came Before The Big Bang Is...
We Don't Know
Okay...  We Might Not Know Right Now
But What Are We Doing To Find The Real Answer
As With Anything In Science
Experts Are Constantly Trying New Things
And Coming Out With Potential Solutions To Difficult Problems
In The Near Future We'll See Launch Of The Long Awaited
James Webb Space Telescope
Which Will Give Us An Unprecedented Ability to See Way Back To The Very Early Universe
And Observe The Formation Of The Very Oldest Galaxies
Perhaps Webb Will Allow Us to Unlock
The Secrets Of The Beginning Of Space And Time
Or Maybe It'll Just Give Us More Questions To Answer
Regardless Of The Outcome
This Is One Of The Biggest And Most Intriguing Riddle
Science Has Yet To Solve
And When We Do Solved It
Our Understanding Of The Universe
And The Very Nature Of Space And Time Will Likely Never Be The Same
What Do You Think?.
Has Our Universe Been Around Forever?.
Did We Come From A Black Hole?.
Or Are We Living In Just One Of Countless Universes
Let Us Know Your Thoughts In The Comments Below
While we wait for answer to this question you should keep track of your own predictions
for how the universe began with a professional website from SquareSpace
So you can tell everyone I told you so when it turns out you're right
with SquareSpace it's not rocket science to create your own
personal website SquareSpace has tons of easy to edit
templates created by world blast designers
to get your shinny website up and running in matter of hours
these days it's so important to have a web presence to showoff your work
sell merchandise or just to be noticed and thanks to SquareSpace
it's a whole lot easier than you might expect
If you enjoyed this video make sure to subscribe
and click the little bell to be notified everytime a new SecondThought video is released
while you're here check out these playlists of other great content
and if you really want to support the channel and get behind the scenes look
at SecondThought check out our Patreon page
Thanks for watching and we'll see you next week!